sur l'île tous sont gagnés par la fièvre
de l'étain
la plupart sont venus des quatre coins
de l'archipel pour exploiter le filon
une catastrophe écologique et des
séquelles irréversibles
l'ONG ou à Lille les Amis de la Terre
dénoncent depuis plusieurs années ses
ravages
selon elle les mines occuperaient les
trois quarts de la superficie de l'île
soit 600000 hectares 65 % des forêts
auraient été rayés de la carte
pour son directeur y estic amundian les
autorités doivent prendre des mesures
fortes pour sauvegarder ce qu'il reste
de l'environnement
nous demandons au gouvernement régional
et central d'appliquer immédiatement un
moratoire sur les activités minières ce
moratoire doit aussi être accompagné
d'un audit environnemental afin que nous
puissions dresser un état des lieux de
la situation
cette audit permettra à terme de nous
assurer des efforts déployés pour
protéger l'environnement
l'entreprise peut être immat s'est
engagée dans une politique de
reboisement de ses anciennes mine une
reforestation souvent réduite à néant
par de nouveaux pilleurs
c'est de notre responsabilité de
replanter lorsque nos concessions
arrivent à expiration mais nous devons
les reboiser nous avons mis en place il
y a 5 ans un plan de reforestation que
nous avons mené à bien nous avons décidé
de renouveler ce plan pour les cinq
prochaines années
en raison de 500 hectares par an nous
allons replanter 2500 hectares de terre
d'après les données que nous avons
récupérées auprès de la compagnie
minière 200 hectares de terre seulement
ont été reboisées
elle continue pourtant de dire que son
plan de réhabilitation a été un succès
en réalité l'environnement est dans un
état pitoyable
l'industrie minière est tout simplement
en train de détruire Banca
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter cette
ruée vers l'étain va même la
pauvrissement de la ressource
le rythme effréné des forages a fini par
épuiser les gisements alors les
compagnies minières et les mineurs
illégaux sont à les prospecter le long
des côtes
tiré par de plus gros profits de plus en
plus de pêcheurs décident de devenir
mineur ils ont transformé leur bateau et
naviguent en grappe arrimés les uns aux
autres
cela leur permet d'explorer le gisement
sur une plus grande surface
[Musique]
dans le nord de l'île la baie de kelabat
abrite plusieurs
îlots paradisiaques comme poulao poutri
l'île princesse son indonésien
il y a quelques mois encore elle était
cernée de radeau et de bateaux feront
les fonds marins
membre de l'ONG compaa Harry darmann sia
n'a pas hésité à défendre ses eaux
turquoises contre les mineurs
les membres de kompalas sont très actifs
à Bangka et nous essayons d'avoir une
approche amicale avec les mineurs
établir
pour leur faire comprendre que leur
activité minière n'est pas autorisée car
elle n'est à l'écosystème de l'île
nous avons constaté que les récifs de
corail étaient recouverts de boue
cependant nous n'avons pas porté de
jugement hâtif sur l'origine de cette
sédimentation
nous avons donc mené des études pour
vérifier l'état de l'estuaire jusqu'à
présent il était propre
à la mer et qui dérive avec le courant
les a comparés avec les sédiments
trouvés sur le corail
on a pu en conclure que c'était les
mêmes et que la pollution provenait donc
de l'activité minière
Harry Darman sia s'est lancé dans une
vaste opération de sauvetage
repiquer dans la baie plus d'une
centaine de plans de corail
ça va rien
bien sûr nous comprenons que les
habitants de Bangka veulent gagner leur
vie grâce au
minesment reverra à la baisse le nombre
de concessions accordées
il doit créer des zones réservées à
l'extraction et des zones naturelles
protégées
car sinon cela ne s'arrêtera jamais
le gouvernement doit s'impliquer dans la
préservation de l'environnement nous
n'avons pas hérité de cette île nous
l'empruntons et nous devons la
transmettre aux générations futures
[Musique]
le combat pour sauver Banca est loin
d'être gagné
l'île dépend largement de l'industrie
minière
60% de son économie repose sur
l'exploitation de l'étain
ni la pêche ni l'agriculture intensive
ne pourront compenser la perte d'une
telle man financière
les mineurs continueront donc de creuser
jusqu'à ce que Banca devienne à jamais
un paradis perdu
[Musique]